Attaching i-cord to the edge of a knitted
piece adds a nice finishing touch.
There are unlimited
variations to this technique.
Here are three for you to try.
The first is plain i-cord along the edge.
The second adds a few extra rows
in between and is a variation
of the worm trim that you may know.
I've heard the third
call a helicopter trim.
Watch and see why this is
a very appropriate name.
Begin by casting on three stitches.
Designer your machine
to slip in one direction.
If you aren't familiar with this, look for
the Knit It Now video on knitting i-cord.
Pick up one loop of the knitted
garment and hang it on the end needle.
This could be an edge stitch or a stitch
on the caston or bound off edge. Knit
across and back,
slipping in one direction.
Repeat this across the edge
of the piece you're finishing.
Try this technique first on your
swatch to check the gauge.
But I generally use the garment
tension to knit an i-cord edge.
When you get to a corner,
just knit a couple of extra rows
without picking up the garment stitch.
Keep picking up and knitting.
Picking up and knitting and soon you'll
see that you have a beautiful edge
that looks great on both sides.
The second i-cord edge is done the same
way, except you knit a few
rows between the pickup.
In this example, we're knitting three rows
with six passes of the carriage
before picking up the next stitch.
Pick up the next stitch or skip a few.
Try it both ways again.
Try this on a swatch.
It tends to flare and may not be
appropriate for your project.
The helicopter trim is done similarly
to the previous edge,
but the trim is twisted before
you pick up the next stitch.
As before, we're knitting three rows
with six passages of the carriage.
Then turn the work for a few turns
and make sure the private side
of the work is facing you
again.
Then pick up the next stitch
of your knitted piece.
Repeat this across the row.
Again, you can pick up the next stitch
or skip a few rows as you can see.
See, the number of turns determines the
shape of the twisted i-cord that forms.
Mastering i-cord will go a long
way in creating your own designs.
Play and have fun with them.